strong Minds discuss ideas
Minds discuss events
weak Minds discuss people
be silent or let thy words be worth more
than silence
we have two ears and one mouth
so we should listen more than we say
man conquers the World by conquering
himself
steal your sensibilities so that life
shall hurt you as little as possible
thou shouldst Eat to Live
not live to eat
by all means marry
if you get a good wife you'll become
happy
if you get a bad one you'll become a
philosopher
smart people learn from everything and
everyone
average people from their experiences
stupid people already have all the
answers
small-minded people blame others average
people blame themselves
the why see all blame as foolishness
whenever they think of you
do what you think is fair
man is not worried by real problems so
much as by his imagined anxieties about
real problems
everywhere man blames nature and fate
yet his fate is mostly but the echo of
his character and passion his mistakes
and his weaknesses
do not spoil what you have by Desiring
what you have not
remember that
what you now have was once among the
things you only hoped for
circumstances don't make the man they
only reveal him to himself
the oldest shortest words yes and no
are those which require the most thought
none can be free who is a slave to
and ruled by his Passions
never discourage anyone who continually
makes progress
no matter how slow
even if that someone is yourself
employ your time in improving yourself
by other men's writings
so that you shall gain easily what
others have labored hard for
reality is created by the mind
we can change our reality by changing
our mind
there is only one way to happiness and
that is to cease worrying about things
which are beyond the power of our will
be careful whom you associate with
it is human to imitate the habits of
those with whom we interact
we inadvertently adopt their interests
their opinions their values
and their habit of interpreting events
false words are not only evil in
themselves
but they infect the soul with evil
rest satisfied with doing well and leave
others to talk of you as they please
a man is never as big as when he is on
his knees to help a child
he is richest who is content with the
least
intent is the wealth of nature
mankind is made of two kinds of people
wise people who know their fools and
fools who think they are wise
men should strive to think much
and know little
if you do not take an interest in the
Affairs of your government
then you are doomed to live under the
rule of fools
a wise man speaks because he has
something to say
a fool because he has to say something
I count him braver who overcomes his
desires than him who conquers his
enemies
for the hardest Victory is over self
in old age
we all regret not having killed laziness
in ourselves
I never desired to please the rabble
would please them I did not learn and
what I knew was far removed from their
understanding
it's not what happens to you
but how you react to it that matters
he who laughs at himself never runs out
of things to laugh at
when we blather about trivial things
we ourselves become trivial
for our attention gets taken up with
trivialities
you become what you give your attention
to
necessity is the strongest of things
for it rules everything
hope is the only good that is common to
all men
those who have nothing else possess hope
still
a fool is known by his speech and a wise
man by silence
let him that would move the world first
move himself
in anger
we should refrain both from speech and
action
the greatest way to live with honor in
this world is to be what we pretend to
be
don't judge your Greatness by your
Shadow at sunset
from the deepest desires often come the
deadliest hate
beware the barrenness of a busy life
do not chase after happiness
it is always in you
he is a man of Courage who does not run
away
but remains at his post and fights
against the enemy
the only true wisdom is in knowing you
know nothing
happiness resides not in possessions and
not in gold
happiness dwells in the soul
in childhood be modest
and youth temperate
in adulthood just
and in old age prudent
by Desiring little a poor man makes
himself rich
lack of activity destroys the good
condition of every human being
no one is more hated than he who speaks
the truth
do not trust all men
but trust men of worth
the former of course is silly
the latter a mark of prudence
the right question is usually more
important than the right answer
courage is the first of human qualities
because it is the quality that
guarantees others
what it lies in our power to do it lies
in our power not to do
let no one be slow to seek wisdom when
he is Young nor weary in the search of
it when he has grown old
for no age is too early or too late for
the health of the Soul
The Misfortune of the wise is better
than the prosperity of the fool
death does not concern us
because as long as we exist
death is not here
and when it does come we no longer exist
the aim of the wise is not to secure
pleasure but to avoid pain
if thou Wilt make a man happy
add not unto his riches but take away
from his desires
the key is to keep company only with
people who uplift you
whose presence calls forth your best
a ship should not ride on a single
anchor
nor life on a single hope
no man ever steps in the same river
twice for it's not the same river
if he's not the same man
do not marry after 40.
because marriage is not provided by
Nature
a confident person avoids two things in
life
Idol gossip and Petty conflicts
choosing instead to cultivate
understanding and Foster Harmony
those who aim at Great Deeds must also
suffer greatly
it is not so much our friends help that
helps us
as the confidence of their help
a bad feeling is a commotion of the Mind
repugnant to reason and against nature
once made equal to man
woman becomes his Superior
our sins are more easily remembered than
our Good Deeds
the wrongdoer is more unfortunate than
the man wronged
foreign